go back to Hannity breaking news now
according to a report the DOJ Inspector
General the one we've been waiting for
has completed a draft of a report as it
relates to the handling of the Clinton
email investigation here with reaction
all of this Ohio Congressman Jim Jordan
Florida congressman Ron de Santos also
with us Fox News contributor Sarah
Carter Sarah let's talk to you first we
we know it's supposed to come in May
who's first supposed to come in April
but they found new information as it
relates to this and new evidence and a
new trail they were following where are
we with this well it looks like it's
wrapped up and and we were expecting it
to wrap up in May they extended that
because they did find new information
and it's going to be imperative I guess
for the inspector general Horowitz to
get all of that information into this
report which I believe he did and now he
will be releasing so this is going to be
very important I mean this is this is
part of what Congress has been asking
for all along remember it's the
inspector general that has all of the
documentation the 1.2 million pieces of
documentation that Congress has been
practically begging for and pushing and
threatening with subpoenas the DOJ and
the FBI so this report is going to be
very important let me go to Congressman
Jim Jordan this is a big breakthrough on
top of the letter that both you Ron
DeSantis and mark Meadows who's not with
us tonight have put out saying the
president you've got to get involved
you've got to tell the Attorney General
and you have the power constitutionally
to do so there's over 1.2 million
documents we're talking about here and
we know with a little bit we've gotten
as anemic Aarthi wrote we've only have a
few of the struck page memos just to
begin with right
couple things first to the inspector
general's report remember it was Michael
Horowitz
who uncovered the page straw text
messages where we've learned so much
information it was also Michael Horowitz
and his team who determined that Andy
McCabe had misled people lied four
different times three times under oath
so we're all anxiously we're waiting
this report I'm sure they'll happen if
it's a draft there'll be some reviews
that have to take place but that that's
good news that we're going to be getting
that soon and more importantly I think
is the letter we sent we're just tired
of the runaround we've been getting from
the Department of Justice it's time for
them to
the information and the one way that we
know that can happen is for the head of
the executive branch the President of
the United States elected by the
American people to tell the Attorney
General the Deputy Attorney General and
the FBI director give Congress a
separate equal branch of government they
would have to do to see yes and that's
what we're asking the president to do
Rhonda Santos let me go to you this is a
very key point we're talking about well
you know again we've only got a small
sampling of the struck page memos and
it's so revealing insurance policies how
much they hate Trump how struck as we've
been reporting tonight is involved in
everything literally interviews Hillary
she's exonerated he's writing it months
before the exoneration before he
interviews Hillary's 17 other witnesses
then a few days later then after they'd
exonerate rig an investigation into
heard now they're investigating Donald
Trump and that the timing as their
George papadopolis story is blowing up
in their face that's why Sean I think
the combination of the IG report hitting
hopefully very soon and then if the
president pulls the trigger on all this
other information we could have the
gusher of information that provides all
the clarity that we've been asking about
all these different questions and yeah
you you talked about the beginning how
did this Russia probe even start very
important questions but even things
going up into the special counsel
I mean Rosenstein writes in a pointing
order appointing Muller the thing's
defective on its face so what does he do
in August he writes a secret addendum a
new appointing order and then they've
redacted most of it they wouldn't even
show that there was a judge that man
afford after they already rated manna
for its home I think the timings
backwards and that shows corruption
Rosen Stein also signing off on that
ridiculous FISA application renewal as
did Sally Yates as we saw in the New
York Times piece today all right Sarah
here's a big question I know the
Inspector General did release some of
the the struck page memo uh text
messages so revealing I don't know
Michael Horowitz I know he's appointed
by Obama why shouldn't we believe he's
going to do their job because the
evidence about Hillary and committing
felonies and obstruction it's
overwhelming and incontrovertible any
any American would get convicted the
fact that they exonerated her before
investigate it's overwhelming and
incontrovertible what makes you think
that we're going to get the truth from
from him look I think there's two things
here that are very revealing and one let
me just start with your question
everyone that I've spoken with every
source that I know who knows Michael
Horowitz says this man is honorable
he'll stick to his guns he will be
straightforward with the American people
and revealed the truth okay so that we
know but we saw that with the McCabe
report I mean he went after McCabe I
think in this one he's gonna go after
Comey
he's gonna go after Loretta Lynch and
that meeting that tarmac meeting he's
gonna look at this scope yes struck and
page and the sort of the Clinton
absolutely absolutely Sean and I want
you to think about the timing of the New
York Times story crossfire hurricane
they knew the DOJ as well as the FBI
that this report was going to come out
and look it came out tonight right so
they needed to cya and they went
straight to the New York Times and tried
to tell their side of the story XY very
limited amazing did you get the same
feeling
the New York Times while trying to
justify and make excuses all they really
did was confirm everything you've
reported and that's right the show was
reported that's right they've confirmed
everything that's been reported that we
have reported and they've also they also
gave away some information they've
talked about at least one mole at least
one source right right so that means
there may have been a big story tomorrow
on the FBI informant that was in the
Trump campaign right am i jumping the
gun here why should we have faith and
great work by why should we have faith
congressmen and congressmen to Sanders
same question in Michael Horowitz well I
mean again I think because he's the one
who actually did tell us what Andy
McCabe was up to he's the one who did
uncover the page struck text messages
that's all good never forget Shawn call
me who's been fired well I think we're
gonna get information about that in this
report of roses record fired a Jim Baker
chief council demoted reassigned I want
to know why that happened we don't know
the answer to that we don't know why
Peters truck is still there and what
he's doing so I think lots of those
things
that we're going to get answers that's
for congressmen to sent us John we need
to trust but verify that's why if the
president releases these documents we
can do for his report and then decide
for ourselves we have everything ition
of the Horowitz report correct that's
right yep